alors qu'attendre de ce nouveau
gouvernement qui sont ces nouveaux
maîtres de l'afghanistan pour en parler
nous sommes avec régis le sommier grand
reporter arte france bonsoir régis merci
d'être avec nous lisons milan ac cet
aliment on imagine que c'était un peu le
casse-tête au final une équipe assez
éclectique alors ils ont mis le temps il
ya eu plusieurs événements on a évoqué
le panchir effectivement le franc
section de prandières probablement
retarder l'annoncé de cette nomination
de deux des principaux ministres n'y a
pas tout le gouvernement encore ce qu on
peut noter c'est que on dirait c'est
l'éclectisme la talibane c'est à dire
que ça compte contient du modéré et du
dur ce gouvernement donc il ya donc le
mollah akoun qui a été nommé donc par le
guide suprême un account zada le
pedigree du mollah akoun on sait c'était
quelqu'un qui était dans l'ancienne
équipe le mollah koons ada le guide
suprême aussi était dans l'équipe
d'anciennes équipe où il chapeautait la
sphère judiciaire on sait qu'à celle
entre 96 et 2001 les talibans ont fait
preuve d'une dureté absolue édictant des
lois quasiment à l'absurde et d'aider
interdite en permanence donc là c'est le
voilà c'est le descendant de cette
équipe là qui dirige aujourd'hui le
mollah akoun fait part à fait partie
aussi de ses anciens talibans et le
mollah baradar qu'on présente souvent
comme un éclairé entre guillemets
quelqu'un qui a négocié avec les
américains pendant huit ans et qui
présente une phase de modération doit
son nom qui veut dire frères c'est le
mollah omar qui l'a appelée baradar
qu'il appelait frère donc la filiation
est les voilà dans l'équipe il ya
comment sirajuddin haqqani qui est une
figure emblématique de l'ale durée
militer combattante c'est à dire de la
wii à l'aide militaire pardon des
talibans et est donc là on a essayé de
satisfaire un petit peu poussé
certains des membres du gouvernement ont
été arrêtés à certains moments soit par
les services pakistanais soit par les
américains certains sont les héritiers
d'ailleurs 2 2 deux figures qui ont été
drones et par la mer par les états unis
donc voilà on peut remarquer d'abord
contrairement à ce qui avait été annoncé
cette possibilité qui est une femme ou
une possibilité qu'il y ait à une figure
de l'opposition abdallah dallas par
exemple ou même certains disaient
peut-être le fils du commandant massoud
tout ça est tellement la vie assez
illusoire et pour le moment c'est de
montrer un front uni entre des talibans
qui n'ont pas forcément été unis
toujours et des gens qui finalement cédé
trouver un ennemi commun avec l'amérique
qui n'ont plus cet ennemi commun donc là
il faut tenir le pouvoir il faut montrer
qu'intérieurement ils sont capables de
le faire et ensuite après il y aura
peut-être des gages pour la seule de la
communauté internationale un sens on
sait que hyères où anthony blinken a
appuyé cette idée d'inclusivité cherrad
un jour yves le drian de la nouvelle
équipe pour le moment elle ne s'est pas
manifesté on sait aussi que c'était ce
que les américains souhaitaient qui lors
des promesses quand même vous le
rappeler hier il ya eu des négociations
avec les talibans et ses promesses
faites aux américains qui pour l'instant
ne sont pas tenues oui tout à fait alors
les promesses elles ont été faites
depuis février 2020 il était question
dans l'accord de paix que les américains
avaient conclu avec le mouvement taliban
qu' il y ait des négociations avec le
gouvernement afghan ces
négociations à l'époque n'ont jamais
rien donné
le gouvernement afghan est tombé là ce
qu'essaie de faire les américains c'est
peut-être de faire une sorte de
marchandage à nouveau un deal avec les
talibans en leur disant montrer un
visage plus ouvert chassez les
extrémistes engagez vous justement à
clarifier vos liens avec al qaïda il
faut rappeler que tous ces gens n'ont
jamais formellement comment remis en
question ce qu'on appelle la bahia c'est
à dire l'acte d'allégeance que oussama
ben laden avait fait au mollah omar qui
a été renouvelé dans toute l'histoire du
mouvement taliban donc je comment le
successeur de ben laden aussi ayman al
zawahiri l'avait fait donc le cette
allégeance aux talibans existe toujours
de la part d'al qaïda donc tout ça c'est
quand même des choses assez trouble les
talibans n'ont pas commenté ce qui
donneront une suite assez à ces actes
une suite à cette filiation et ça c'est
très important pour la communauté
internationale en particulier pour les
américains mais pas seulement également
les chinois les russes vous rappeliez
dans le reportage que aucun des pays
pour le mandat vers oro n'avait reconnu
le gouvernement taliban ça se produira
et les talibans ont fait d'ailleurs
appel à l'allemagne disons qu'il
souhaitait entretenir des relations
évidemment pour des questions
financières on imagine bien parce que
encore une fois ce qui est très
important pour elle c'est pouvoir tenir
le pays asseoir leur souveraineté sur
l'ensemble du pays ce qui est très
difficile en afghanistan et puis gérer
l'économie et des finances dans un pays
qui est un des plus pauvres de la
planète et qui a énormément énormément
de carence encore aujourd'hui en tout
cas du chef des talibans ce soir à a
pris la parole ils demandent au nouveau
gouvernement de défendre la charia c'est
l'une des premières déclarations ça dit
quoi justement ce sont 6 2 de défense de
la charia alors lâchez rien vous savez
quand on va voir les talibans j'ai
toujours quelque chose c'est toujours
quelque chose qui mettent ils vous
disent par exemple ou leur dit allez
vous recommencez à interdire comment le
sport aux femmes les cigarettes la
musique etc et ils vous répondent en
disant tout ce que la charia art
autorise jeu l'autoriserait tout ce
qu'elle interdit je l'interdirait c'est
toujours très facile espèce de paravent
permanent chez les talibans de dire nous
appliquerons la charia maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça signifie concrètement
est ce que ça signifie mettre en cause
le droit des femmes visiblement ce qu'on
aura encore ce qu'on remarque c'est que
il y à des manifestations de femmes qui
demandent leur droit à kaboul et dans la
plupart des villes du pays en a eu même
jusqu'à elle dit djalal abad sont comme
des zones très très conservatrice pour
le moment certaines de ces
manifestations a été contrarié les
talibans ont tiré en l'air à kaboul pour
disperser une mais il n'y a pas eu
comment dire de scène comme on avait pu
les voir lors de leur arrivée au pouvoir
en 96 c'est à dire des lynchages des
pendaisons
des exécutions dans les stades ça on l'a
pas vu il ya eu des règlements de
comptes mais des règlements de comptes
discrètement contre les ennemis
traditionnels les talibans c'est à dire
des forces armées formé par les
américains qui étaient véritablement les
ennemis des talibans pendant 20 ans donc
ça il ya eu ce genre d'exactions pour le
moment sur les manifestations des femmes
on les a vus elle donc pu se dérouler là
apparemment ils les ont interdites on
dit qu'il ne souhaitait pas qu'elle se
reproduise on va voir dans les jours
prochains comment ils vont se comporter
surtout si ces femmes qui ont bien
l'intention de continuer à redescendre
dans les rues et à acclamer leurs droits
continuent à le faire